gentlemen ladies what if Superman had  decided to fly down rip off the roof of  the White House  grab the president right out of the Oval  Office who would have stopped him  I want to build a team of some very bad  people who I think can do some good  y'all Joker's must be crazy  this is the deal you disobey me you die  throughout escape hatch you die  I'm gonna boyfriend you irritate or vex  me I'm known to be quite vexing I'm just  full warning you you duh they get caught  we throw them under the bus  I'm gonna ride let's play Mon get  something better  I love this guy  that good don't forget where the bad  guys are you sweet-talking me all of  that chit chats gonna getcha  will do CSUN oh yeah one who sings dumb  yes I want to see stop I was just trying  to get you there  no I feel is right we good beer whiskey  what am i 12 how do you have stuff water  that's a good idea  you